- All right, gentlemen.
Now we're going to get
to the heart of who
is our next "Forged in Fire"
champion by testing your blades
in a kill test,
a sharpness test,
and, of course, up
first, the strength test.
Dave?
All right, gentlemen.
Now here on "Forged
in Fire" we have
a small elite group
we like to call
the Bulletproof Blade Club.
Hopefully you'll
both be joining.
To test the strength
of your weapon,
we'll be firing a
.45-caliber round
at the edge of that blade.
Now you're both veterans.
The .45's a military weapon,
so the cutlass you made
is a military sword.
So we're going to use our own
military weapon in this test.
Third ranger battalion
and former Air
Force para-rescuemen,
Will Willis
will be firing the round.
All right, Jon.
You're up first.
You ready?
Hell yeah.
The fact that Will
is going to fire
freehand his pistol at my
blade, I can't believe this.
[bleep] damn.
A sword is not meant to meet
up with a bullet on its edge.
I am sweating bullets,
no pun intended.
[music playing]
[gunshot]
There it is.
Woo!
All right.
Jon, I was running my
fingernail across here,
and I thought I was feeling
nicks in your blade.
What I'm actually feeling
is material from the bullet
that's hung up on the edge.
Congratulations.
You got a bulletproof sword.
Thank you, sir.
All right, Mike.
You ready for this?
Let's do this.
OK.
[music playing]
[gunshot]
I think that did it.
So Mike, your blade
held up really well.
You can see, right
here, where that bullet
went right across the blade.
The edge is still there.
Welcome to the club.
Bladesmiths, this
is the kill test.
Let's see how deadly
your weapons are.
Jon, you're up first.
You ready?
Rock and roll.
I built this thing to kill.
It's not some
flashy museum piece.
[music playing]
I didn't think
it went that deep.
All right, Jon.
First up, the
handle construction
is comfortable with me.
I had no issues at all with
this catching on anything.
I was able to move around it.
The point easily pierced
through this and lacerates
on the way out.
The balance of the
weight of the blade
is forward enough to
where I cut through right
into the clavicle, into
the ribs, into the lungs.
Jon, this weapon will kill.
Thank you, sir.
Mike, you're ready.
You up for this?
Let's do it.
[music playing]
All right, Mike.
Let's talk about your
cutlass right here.
First up, it's a lot
heavier than the other sword
but it's all centered down here.
That curved edge
really lends itself
to a nice lacerating weapon.
The only one thing I
have to say about this
is it's a very big handle.
There's a lot of
space right here.
So I have to choke up to get
the right feel for the blade.
But overall, sir, it will kill.
Good job.
Thank you.
Jon, Mike, we here
at "Forged in Fire"
want to thank you
for your service.
I'm a former service
member, so is Doug.
We understand that sacrifice.
In this arena of competition,
there can only be
one "Forged in Fire" champion.
Both of your blades performed
exactly as we expect them to.
They're strong, they're
sharp, they're deadly,
so this is a decision that came
down to the finest details.
Our new "Forged in
Fire" champion is Jon.
Congratulations.
Mike, unfortunately your
blade did not make the cut.
This is why we have
these kinds of competitions
when it comes to be that close.
So we have to look
at the finest detail.
What we looked at now was
the handle construction
of your blade.
There are some hot
spots and some gapping,
and that's the reason
why you didn't win.
OK.
I have a hard time
saying this Devil Dog,
but it's time to
give up that weapon.
I think I really
represented myself.
I did a really good job.
Jon just beat me
in a fine detail.
That's it.
- Congratulations.
Semper fi, buddy.